I grew up drinking slushies like a lot
of slushie flavors are made up flavors
like blue raspberry does not exist
I can't wonder I feel like I'm at a
winery except just less expensive and
classy feel like a child I'm good it is
good there's a little sour this mainly
poke with a fruity blend lemonade and
coke I think it's coke and blue
raspberry it's it's coke and watermill
like that I wish I had something to
clear my palate but okay copy that sour
hmm nuns like a jolly rancher in a
Slurpee blue raspberry seems pretty good
but there's I know but sometimes they
say blue raspberry I'm at red I feel
like it must be a watermelon sherry I'm
gonna go with cherry and watermelon I'm
gonna go with that too
our final answer is sour watermelon and
sharing watermelons
before I taste it I'm gonna guess it's
dirt it's sewage it's like tootsie roll
is a flavor I would guess tootsie roll I
don't think coke is in here and I like
bananas in here Pina Colada I don't
taste it all cherry I taste a little bit
candy coconut in there we're taking this
one way too seriously no we're not coke
watermelon cherry yep I live in a banana
hey banana sure blue raspberry banana
watermelon coke what's the last one
I need pina colada all right although I
do watermelons sour pina colada
banana coke and I'm spilling on that Mel
made it's lemonade wait do we say
goodbye either
no I knew it
no you